if at first you don't succeed try and
try again so keen will US authorities to
get their hands on an Iranian owned oil
tanker they used everything at their
disposal first came the stick accusing
the tanker of moving oil to Syria in
breach of sanctions they went to the UK
for help
British Marines impounded the ship while
it was passing through the Strait of
Gibraltar Spanish Foreign Minister said
the arrest came after a demand from the
u.s. to the UK
but on 15th of August Gibraltar released
the vessel it set sail into the
Mediterranean a few days later after
being renamed from grace one to Adrien
Dario one
then came the carat we've all had one of
those emails I'm writing to you with
good news what might you expect a
surprise lottery win
perhaps a huge inheritance from a
long-lost royal family member in Africa
well that's exactly the email that the
ship's captain received but this wasn't
your regular spam for the junk folder
this came direct from the State
Department this is Brian hook I work for
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo and serve
as the US representative for Iran the
offer millions of dollars for captain
Kumar to dock his Iranian tanker in a
u.s. friendly port that would allow its
seizure by Washington after the possibly
confused captain failed to reply a
second email hit his inbox the tone now
less friendly with this money
you can have any life you wish and be
well off in old age if you choose not to
take this easy path life would be much
harder for you what lay behind this
thinly veiled threat was left to his
imagination Tehran was understandably
roiled having failed at piracy the u.s.
resource to outright blackmail deliver
us Iran's oil and received several
million dollars or be sanctioned
yourself sounds very similar to the Oval
Office invitation I received a few weeks
back it is becoming a pattern incredibly
the State Department confirmed to this
unusual strategy even adding this was no
one-off will have conducted extensive
outreach to several ship captains as
well as shipping companies captain Kumar
meanwhile is on the US naughty list how
differently this story would have ended
if only captain Kumar had cashed in and
just answered that
good news email anyone who said the
Adrienne Darya one wasn't headed to
Syria is in denial Tarun thinks it's
more important to fund the murder Assad
regime than provide for its own people
we can talk but Iran's not getting any
sanctions relief
until it stops lying and spreading
terror the fact that they tried to bribe
the captain of the tanker and then
subsequently threatened him is
extraordinary and it should be something
that people in the United States would
be talking about day and night but there
are also other issues as well Bolton
wants to intimidate Iran and the very
fact that he has failed and the Iranian
super tanker is alongside the Syrian
shore reveals that failure so he's
outraged at another level he wants to
make the Syrian people suffer as much as
possible because that's been US policy
for many years now and on the other hand
he wants to prevent Iran from carrying
out trade with other countries through
bullying and threats and illegal
behavior so there are multiple reasons
for the u.s. behavior toward Iran
towards Syria and towards all
independent countries but I think it's
only harming the United States in the
long run because the United States is
increasingly seen as a rogue regime
you